you know I think a little bit of this
also is what Bill Maher refers to as the
the bigotry or the soft bigotry of low
expectations do you feel that that
somehow these people and again I'm
talking about the white liberals in this
group that they think because you think
differently than they want you to think
but yeah that shows racism right thank
you
you could cut right now into your show
when you when you do your production
yeah an image of me stalking me talking
to Sam Harris and being called a porch
monkey for it yeah and me talking to
Morgan Freeman now now the question I
ask is why why would none of these guys
and they haven't dancers why would any
of these guys not call me a porch monkey
for talking to Morgan Freeman it's not
call me his native informant not call me
his porch monkey yeah when I'm talking
to a white man mm-hmm it gives porch
monkey they call me his native
informants that's the racism of low
expectations it's the assumption that
when a brown man is talking to a brown
man it's the meeting of equals but when
a brown man is talking to a white land
that brown man suddenly loses all agency
and can't think for himself and is
following the white man's thoughts and
yet the irony is that I don't even use
that form of identity politics to
describe people I don't see people as
white people brown people I see Pete's
effectively I use I I like people to
look at people as their values you know
as liberal if someone's Islamist if
someone's you know conservative that's
how I look at people as it tells me
where I stand with them much more than
skin color does but these are the people
who are who are ostensibly anti-racist
deploying that form of racism and you'll
find that you know I tweeted an image of
Morgan Freeman and these yesterday and
put it on my Facebook page I have not
once heard any reaction from any of this
regressive left phenomenon in the sense
of being called his native informant or
his Muslim or his porch monkey it hasn't
simply hasn't happened and that there is
a best example of the reverse racism of
low expectations you've just referred to
yeah so I have been using the term
regressive left also I just started
using it in the last few weeks and a few
of my my friends that are in this space
aren't thrilled with me because of it
but I think what you're exposing there
is a fatal flaw of progressivism because
they view things in the prism of
identity politics it's very hard to
extricate someone with a separate idea
or someone that doesn't fit the the
cliche and you're literally a walking
breathing example of that which is
explains why you get the the [ __ ] that
you do and it's important to mention at
the same time when I'm sitting there I
tweet out that I am I was made Morgan
Freeman in the mosque explaining you
know having a conversation about the
difference between Islamism it is
important to mention that at the same
time I got lots of reaction from people
saying the difference between Islam and
Islamism is in your head and actually
you know they're the same thing so
there's also that that side of the
reaction you know I get it from that
side to people insisting that Islam is
what they believe it to be which is what
I was kind of them and I'm just engaged
myself in a form of apology for what
Islam is and so it's it's it's difficult
to try and strike this balance where you
know we need honesty in this
conversation we need people to accept
that there's a problem with Islamist
extremism and there's also in fact a
challenge in dealing with taking Islam
out of its medieval heyday the paradigms
the theological paradigms that were
developed in the era that we simply
haven't moved on from and actually that
means that a whole bunch of Muslims so
the Islamists are but you don't like me
a whole bunch of traditionalist
non-islamist conservative Muslims don't
like me because I talk about reforming
the interpretation and then a whole
bunch of anti Muslim people on the other
side who want me to a pasta size don't
like me because because I say Islam can
be interpreted and they want me to say
that Islam is evil so you know you end
up getting kind of stuck in this middle
and it requires a lot of patience yeah
well I guess if you have a lot of people
hating you you might be telling the
truth you don't need to be a believer in
Islam to concede the point which is the
point I was making with Sam who I think
has since shifted in his view and his
accepting that he's view has changed
somewhat on this point you don't need to
be a believer in the religion of Islam
to concede that texts can be interpreted
it's not as simple as saying I'm gonna
go to a restaurant and order a lobster
and if you bring your
why did you bring the chicken when I
ordered a lobster because menu says
mobster you're ordering one thing there
what we're talking about is a manual bit
like a car manual when something's gone
wrong in the engine and reading the
whole thing and working out what the
diagnosis is you know where the
particular relevant parts are how you
put them together we're talking about
complex ideas like that like
interpreting Scripture and adapting them
to the time and space we find ourselves
in you know by definition it's an
exercise in interpretation and that's
why even with a US constitution you've
got the same document being used as a
source for pro-choice and pro-life
people's or pro gun laws and and and gun
restriction people using the very same
document to make their arguments because
the dispute is over what the document
means in this day and age in the first
place and so you don't really need to
believe in the scripture to concede that
there is no one definitive reading of
Shakespeare there's no one definitive
reading on the Bible and there's no one
definitive reading of the Quran yeah all
right so one more piece on this portion
of all this what do you make of the term
islamaphobe because to me the the term
itself has a lot of problems with it
because I don't think people fear Islam
as in the religion they fear if they're
if there is a fear for some people it's
the actions they fear the actions that
people are taking in the name of the
religion and again that I know that can
be confusing for people because that's
the idea
verse the people but I do see this meme
of calling everyone in Islamophobia and
it goes of course to a lot of things
we've talked about so far but I fear
that their use of that word also is
creating a real a real backlash to what
they want to accomplish well they see
often this word is deployed to silence
you know it's used to kind of muzzle the
debate when people have every right to
criticize and scrutinize and satirize
any idea whether it's Christianity he's
science whether it's religion whether
it's Islam any idea is open to scrutiny
in fact that's the the essence of
progress it's how our societies have
ended up where they are today and every
innovator for their day was a blasphemer
yes Galileo questioned things that he
was called a heretic what was considered
a heretic for the theory of evolution
and so
you know and even prophets were heretics
against the old religion you know
whether that's Muhammad Jesus almost so
at the end of the day if it wasn't for
blasphemy if it wasn't for in other
words questioning established norms and
heresy we wouldn't have progress so to
use the word Islamophobia to silence any
scrutiny of an idea would be to hinder
this debate and the progress that is
needed in this debate I don't like the
term for that reason and I think it's
deployed too often against people who
are simply questioning whether you know
whether Islam needs to be reformed on us
or whether Islamism has a relationship
to Islam which of course it does
you know Islamism is an offshoot of
Islam it's wrong to say it's got nothing
to do with this long and so people that
have been asking these questions to deal
with some very real problems in the
world are being called Islamophobes
that's actually unfair I prefer the word
anti-muslim bigoted there is such a
thing as R&T Muslim bigoted or there are
absolute there are people who like
Carson who don't believe in perhaps
don't even but they also don't want
Muslim presidents of the United States
what do you do with the neuroscientist
who doesn't believe in evolution those
things don't seem like they should add
up but the kind of indicates you know
that they're so there is something about
people that have they want to
discriminate against people like me
because of the religion I was born into
is that that's that's anti-muslim
bigotry but has very different to
scrutinizing Islam the idea and that's
why I develop this maxim which again the
dialogue with Sam and that is that no
idea should be or is ever above scrutiny
no idea is above screws and you know
people are beneath dignity and I think
that really nicely summarizes whether we
should stand on this debate yeah that's
actually a great segue for my next
question which is what has the the
reaction from just sort of the
mainstream Muslim community in England
been to you because when I even when I
tweeted out that we were gonna sit down
and do this the majority of it was
positive now obviously we have a certain
amount of people that follow both of us
and know what we think about things that
enjoy what we do so that's expected but
I did get some people that said oh you
know it was the it was this porch monkey
mentality oh he's just doing this for
for money and affection of white people
you know a lot of that what I think is
pure nonsense but what what about the
mainstream Muslim
that you're around every day well look
you know mainstream Muslims aren't
Islamists they are conservative but
they're not Islamists and they're
certainly not jihadists and so what
they're not going to do even if they
disagree with me is they're not gonna
you know they're not gonna basically
attack me for it or launch into a tirade
of hominem even if they disagree
now I'm very realistic about where I
stand among my own religious communities
that's because if I have just was
treated myself to challenging Islamism I
probably would have had the support of
the overwhelming majority the mainstream
of Muslims but the other arming
mainstream also happened to be in social
and religious matters conservative with
a small seat and I challenge that too I
call for reform in our approach and
interpretation of the scripture I am a
liberal socially as well as politically
and another mention I'm a member of the
Liberal Democrats in the United Kingdom
which is the centrist party there and so
you know I have very openly supported a
lot of social reforms on these issues
and I think that you know we have some
arsenic William who advocated for the
reconciliation of evolution creat these
fanuc weed that was incredibly
controversial when he did so he was
kicked out of his mosque for that and
that's not an Islamist mosque it's a
conservative mosque and so the reason
that that you will sense a lot of
backlash it's because we take on the
twin challenges of wanting to again
another sort of maxim is that it you
know what we want to do is that Islamism
must be intellectually terminated
whereas Islam needs to be reformed but
that's the twin challenge that faces us
and it means that obviously because no
change is seamless all change is painful
a lot of people get upset when they come
here some of the things we say but
that's the nature of change I mean you
know that's how societies change it's
it's it's it's normal yeah I know you
might be slightly hesitant to talk about
this but can I ask you just in terms of
your own personal safety I'm sure you
are you are threatened I know that that
a lot of the other people in this space
from bill to Sam to many others have a
certain amount of threatened that they
deal with from from all fronts by the
way you know I think from someone like
it comes from people from radical
Christians too so I don't even I don't
even want to make this about Islam or
Muslims particularly but people I think
need to understand that you put yourself
at great risk to talk about the things
that you're talking about right yeah we
don't want to dwell on this but yeah
it's not exactly the safest occupation
in the heart